welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with this nothing fun about it at all
hours before today's public impeachment
hearings there are new revelations from
an official who says that they overheard
a call to President Trump in a
restaurant four officials will testify
today including three who have
first-hand knowledge of the July 25th
call at the center of this inquiry
between President Trump and the
president of Ukraine this latest
bombshell from closed-door testimony is
about a call from the next day State
Department official David Holmes says he
heard the president ask EU Ambassador
Gordon Sandland about something called
the investigation Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill forced Nancy good morning
what else did we learn good morning well
home says that he remembers this call
from a Ukrainian cafe so vividly because
he had never seen anything like it quote
someone calling the president from a
mobile phone at a restaurant and then
having a conversation of this level of
candor and colorful language but it's
what Holmes had to say about what the
Ukrainians knew about the holdup in
military aid that is poking holes in the
president's defense the newly released
transcript shows career diplomat David
Holmes told lawmakers that the
Ukrainians gradually came to understand
that they were being asked to do
something in exchange for a meeting
between President Trump and President
Solinsky and the security assistance
hold being lifted it's unclear exactly
when the Ukrainians became aware but
President Solinsky has claimed he never
felt any pressure nobody pushing me
polls his testimony contradicts one of
the GOP s main arguments I trust the
fact that the Ukrainians didn't know
that eight had been held and Ukrainians
did nothing to get it released when I
was released today's testimony will
involve three witnesses who were on the
July 25th call where President Trump
pushed zalenski to look into former Vice
President Joe Biden and his son Jennifer
Williams a State Department aide
detailed to the vice president's office
described the call as unusual and
inappropriate Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander vinden a national security
council official said he did not think
it was proper
and the president's top Russia advisor
Tim Morrison said he had concerns too
but didn't think anything illegal was
discussed California Democrat Jackie
Speier video here from all of them was
not just the fourth witness ambassador
Kurt Volker was one of the so-called
three amigos officials with a direct
line to President Trump who unofficially
took over Ukraine policy just before mr.
Trump froze hundreds of millions in aid
to Ukraine
Under Secretary of State David Hales
testimony was also released overnight
he said Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
was most likely the person who decided
not to public or former ambassador
Murray Ivanovich when she was the target
of a smear campaign led by Rudy Giuliani
this is not a time to undercut our
diplomats Pompeo again declined to
specifically defend Evanovich yesterday
I always defend State Martin points to
the greatest diplomatic corps in the
history of the world very proud of the
team Holmes who overheard that phone
call also testified that he thought it
was surprising that Sandlin used his
cell phone to call the President of the
United States because at least two of
the three mobile networks in Ukraine are
owned by Russian companies and so
Americans typically assume that the
Russians are listening in that's another
question that song one will have to
answer when he testifies here tomorrow
Tony a lot of people looking forward to
that Nancy thank you very much